Thanks to President Obama's Affordable Care Act, integrated care has become a major priority within the health care industry. But what is integrated care? How does it affect children, families, and older adults? And what are patient-centered medical homes? In this episode, we break down the ins and outs of integrated care with a psychologist who is a leading researcher on integrated care. I'm Audrey Hamilton, and this is speaking of psychology. Joan Asarno is director of the Youth Stress and Mood Program, and a professional. Professor of Psychiatry and Biobehavioral Sciences at UCLA. Her research focuses on strategies for improving health and mental health and youth with an emphasis on suicide prevention and depression.
得益于奥巴马总统的《平价医疗法案》，整合医疗已成为医疗保健行业的一项重中之重。但什么是整合医疗？它如何影响儿童、家庭和老年人？什么是患者中心医疗之家？在本期节目中，我们与一位研究整合医疗的顶尖心理学家一起探讨了整合医疗的方方面面。我是奥黛丽·汉密尔顿，这里是《心理学访谈》。琼·阿萨诺是加州大学洛杉矶分校青少年压力与情绪项目的主任，也是精神病学和生物行为科学的教授。她的研究重点是改善青少年健康和心理健康的策略，尤其强调自杀预防和抑郁症。
She was also on the American Psychological Association's Task Force on Patient-Centered Medical Homes. Welcome, Dr. Arsarno. Thank you. I'm delighted to be here. Your primary area of research focuses on mental health care and prevention for children and teenagers. You've also been publishing research on the effect collaborative care settings have on these children. Can you talk about that? I would be happy too. You know, in the United States, we can obtain outstanding medical care. And we can obtain outstanding care for behavioral health problems,
她还曾担任美国心理学会患者中心医疗之家工作组的成员。欢迎您，阿萨诺博士。谢谢。很高兴来到这里。您的主要研究领域是儿童和青少年的心理健康护理与预防。您还发表了关于协同护理环境对这些儿童产生影响的研究。能谈谈这个吗？我很乐意。你知道，在美国，我们可以获得出色的医疗护理。我们也可以获得出色的行为健康问题护理，
a broad term that we use to refer to mental health and substance abuse problems and health risk behaviors. We can get the best mental health and substance abuse care in the world in the United States. but where we have the problems is in getting that care to people. From the perspective of kids in mental health, we have some really major problems. First of all, there are very high rates of mental health problems among our kids. Estimates for adolescents indicate that 40% of our adolescents suffer from mental health or substance use disorders within any year. And in younger kids, it's one out of eight kids who are estimated.
这是一个广泛使用的术语，用来指代心理健康、药物滥用问题以及健康风险行为。在美国，我们可以获得世界上最好的心理健康和药物滥用护理。但我们遇到问题的地方在于如何将这些护理送到人们手中。从心理健康儿童的角度来看，我们存在一些非常重大的问题。首先，儿童中的心理健康问题发病率非常高。针对青少年的估计表明，在任何一年中，有40%的青少年遭受心理健康或药物使用障碍的困扰。而在较小的儿童中，据估计每八个孩子中就有一个。
to suffer for mental health disorders during a year. This translates to about 16 million children in the United States who suffer for mental health or substance abuse problems. The second really alarming fact is that over half of those kids with a documented need for mental health care receive no services for those problems. And this unmet need is associated with lack of insurance and minority status, And when treated, members of racial and ethnic minority groups and poor children also tend to receive poor quality of care compared to non-minorities.
在一年中遭受心理健康障碍的困扰。这意味着美国大约有1600万儿童遭受心理健康或药物滥用问题的困扰。第二个令人震惊的事实是，在这些有明确心理健康护理需求的儿童中，有一半以上没有接受任何针对这些问题的服务。这种未满足的需求与缺乏保险和少数族裔身份有关，而且在接受治疗时，与非少数族裔相比，少数族裔群体成员和贫困儿童也往往接受质量较差的护理。
And this contributes to disparities in care and health outcomes. We had a study that came out in JAMA Pediatrics in August 2015 that was designed to ask the question, if you put care for behavioral health problems into primary care services, does that lead to improve? behavioral health for our kids as compared to usual primary care services. And we did this study because this is a time of dramatic changes in our health care environment. And at a time like this, it's really very critical for us as psychologists to look at our scientific base and look at how our science can inform these changes so that we can do our very best to make sure that these changes that are occurring lead to the changes. lead to real improvements in the health of our kids.
这导致了护理和健康结果方面的差距。我们在2015年8月的《JAMA儿科学》杂志上发表了一项研究，旨在探讨这样一个问题：如果你将行为健康问题的护理纳入初级保健服务中，与常规初级保健服务相比，这是否能改善我们儿童的行为健康？我们之所以做这项研究，是因为我们正处于医疗保健环境发生剧烈变化的时期。在这样的时刻，我们作为心理学家，审视我们的科学基础，并探讨我们的科学如何为这些变化提供信息至关重要，这样我们就能尽最大努力确保正在发生的这些变化能够带来真正的改变。切实改善我们孩子的健康。
As you know, there's recent legislation that's affected health care, and it's also affected behavioral health care for our kids. Affordable Care Act, right? Right. The Affordable Care Act aims to achieve a healthier population and improve access to care, also improve quality of care in the patient experience of care while reducing costs.
如你所知，最近的立法影响了医疗保健，也影响了我们孩子的行为健康护理。《平价医疗法案》，对吧？是的。《平价医疗法案》旨在实现更健康的民众并改善护理获取，同时在降低成本的同时提高护理质量和患者体验。
And a major part of this, is that mental health and substance use services are included as essential health benefits, which means that they must be included as part of a comprehensive package and insurance packages. We have one other piece of legislation that's had a big impact on behavioral health, and that's the mental health and addiction parity legislation that was passed in 2008, and that provides increased access to insurance for behavioral health problems. So one approach to improving access to high-quality behavioral health care is to bring that behavioral health care into the settings where kids are already receiving cares.
其中一个主要部分是，心理健康和药物使用服务被作为基本健康福利纳入其中，这意味着它们必须作为综合服务包和保险服务包的一部分包含在内。我们还有另一项对行为健康产生重大影响的立法，那就是2008年通过的心理健康和成瘾奇偶校验立法，该立法为行为健康问题提供了更多的保险获取途径。因此，改善高质量行为健康护理获取途径的一种方法是将行为健康护理引入孩子们已经在接受护理的环境中。
And that's really been one of the things that's motivated efforts to integrate care for mental health and substance use problems within our primary care settings. Right. So do you think that as primary care providers are equipped as it is to recognize mental health problems, especially in children, such as depression, anxiety, you know, what can be done better in your view? Well, I think that that's what this study was designed to do. First of all, I think we can train and provide resources. We have data that shows this to help primary care providers to screen for behavioral health problems and to help kids to get the care that they need.
这确实是推动在初级保健环境中整合心理健康和药物使用问题护理的努力的动力之一。是的。那么你认为目前的初级保健提供者是否具备识别心理健康问题（尤其是儿童中的抑郁症、焦虑症等）的能力，在你看来，有哪些方面可以做得更好？嗯，我认为这正是本期研究旨在做的事情。首先，我认为我们可以进行培训并提供资源。我们有数据表明，这有助于初级保健提供者筛查行为健康问题，并帮助儿童获得所需的护理。
But there have been a number of studies, in fact, we found 31 of them involving over 13,000 and kids where they use different approaches to support primary care in providing care for behavioral health problems. And the real benefit of this is it brings care to the place where kids are. And that reduces barriers to behavioral health care like stigma. Kids don't want to admit oftentimes that they're suffering from depression or other mental health problems. And there are just practical complications involved in shifting from one doctor to another,
但已经有许多研究，事实上，我们发现了31项涉及13000多名儿童的研究，他们使用不同的方法来支持初级保健提供专业行为健康问题护理。这样做真正的益处在于，它将护理带到了孩子们所在的地方。这减少了行为健康护理的障碍，比如污名化。孩子们常常不想承认自己患有抑郁症或其他心理健康问题。而且，从一个医生转到另一个医生，其中涉及实际的复杂性，
one clinic to another, and often we see that kids and families aren't able to follow up with a recommendation to see a specialty mental health provider in a different office. Right. So if they're there, the access to care is much easier for everyone involved, the physician, the parent, the child. Yeah. And in our study, which was a meta-analysis, which means that we looked at results across multiple different studies, this is an approach that's used increasingly in evidence-based medicine in order to help with clinical decision-making so that we know what works, and then doctors and other providers are able to match kids to the kinds of treatments that they're most likely to benefit from.
从一个诊所转到另一个诊所，我们经常看到儿童和家庭无法落实去看不同办公室的专业心理健康提供者的建议。对吧。因此，如果他们就在那里，每个人获取护理的途径就会容易得多，包括医生、家长和儿童。是的。在我们的研究中，这是一项荟萃分析，这意味着我们查看了多个不同研究的结果，这是循证医学中越来越多地使用的一种方法，有助于临床决策，以便我们了解什么有效，然后医生和其他提供者能够将儿童与他们最有可能从中受益的治疗方法进行匹配。
And in our study where we looked at integrated care programs, and they were really a very diverse range of integrated care programs, what was very exciting is that we found that when you made behavioral health care, available through primary care, we had a statistically significant benefit for kids' behavioral health as compared to usual primary care. And that's a big deal because we looked across multiple different kinds of behavioral health problems and many different kinds of approaches to integrating care. So the probability was actually 66% that a randomly selected child would have a better outcome after receiving integrated care than a randomly selected child after receiving
在我们的研究中，我们研究了整合医疗项目，它们确实是一系列非常多样化的整合医疗项目，非常令人兴奋的是，我们发现，当你通过初级保健提供行为健康护理时，与常规初级保健相比，对儿童的行为健康具有统计学上显著的益处。这是一件大事，因为我们研究了多种不同类型的行为健康问题以及许多不同类型的整合医疗方法。因此，随机挑选的儿童在接受整合医疗后获得更好结果的可能性实际上是66%，而随机挑选的儿童在接受
usual care. I want to switch gears a little bit on to when we talked about Affordable Care Act, the ACA, you know, it's expanding the use of what are called patient-centered medical homes, and you participated, you mentioned this, in a task force that evaluated research on the role psychologists play in such places. Can you explain? Because I don't think a lot of our listeners may know what a patient-centered medical care. home is and then can you talk about, you know, what you found? That's a fabulous question. You know,
常规护理后。我想稍微转换一下话题，谈谈当我们谈到《平价医疗法案》（ACA）时，你知道，它正在扩大被称为患者中心医疗之家（patient-centered medical homes）的使用，你参与了你提到的一个工作组，该工作组评估了心理学家在这些地方发挥作用的研究。你能解释一下吗？因为我认为我们的许多听众可能不知道什么是患者中心医疗之家，然后你能谈谈你发现了什么吗？这是一个极好的问题。你知道，
when I first heard the term, patient-centered medical home or medical home, I had this vision of this really comfortable house with comfortable chairs and we were all sitting around a table with a cup of tea and I was talking to my doctor and he was helping me feel better and all was good. Well, it could be like that. But really, the idea of a health home or a patient-centered medical home isn't a place. It's not that we're referring to a place. It's a philosophy or a model for achieving primary care excellence that's designed to provide people with care at the right time and the right place and in a way that best meets their needs. There are five major components of the patient-centered medical home as defined by the Agency for Healthcare Research and Quality.
当我第一次听到“患者中心医疗之家”或“医疗之家”这个词时，我的脑海里浮现出这样一幅画面：一个非常舒适的房子，里面有舒适的椅子，我们都围坐在一张桌子旁，手里端着一杯茶，我正在和我的医生交谈，他正在帮我感觉好点，一切都很好。嗯，它可能是那样的。但实际上，“健康之家”或“患者中心医疗之家”的概念并不是一个地方。我们指的不是一个地方。它是实现初级保健卓越性的哲学或模型，旨在以最能满足人们需求的方式，在正确的时间和正确的地点为人们提供护理。根据医疗保健研究和质量局的定义，患者中心医疗之家有五个主要组成部分。
So the first is that the PCMH, I'll call it PCMH, patient-centered medical home. Right. Okay, the PCMH is supposed to be comprehensive. That means it includes both medical care and care for mental health and substance use problems. Secondly, surprise, surprise, it refers to the need to be patient-centered. So that means an active partnership between patients and their doctors and other clinicians that really focuses on things that patients care about and value. and really conveys a respect for patients and families.
因此，首先是PCMH，我将其称为PCMH，即患者中心医疗之家。好的。好的，PCMH应该是全面的。这意味着它既包括医疗护理，也包括心理健康和药物滥用问题的护理。其次，意料之中，它指的是需要以患者为中心。这意味着患者与其医生和其他临床医生之间建立积极的伙伴关系，真正关注患者关心和重视的事情，并真正表达对患者和家属的尊重。
The third is coordination, and that means that different doctors and different clinicians talk to each other. So if I break my toe and I go for an x-ray and I go to see somebody to help me with my toe, not only will the person I saw for the toe and the x-ray know about it, but my primary care doctor will know about it too so that he could also check on me, or she could also check on me if they need to. The fourth component is accessibility, the idea that you can actually get an appointment. Then an appointment is available. And additionally, within the PCMH, approaches are used other than appointments, like telephone coaching or telephone outreach to help get patients the care that they need.
第三是协调，这意味着不同的医生和不同的临床医生彼此沟通。因此，如果我的脚趾骨折了，我去拍X光片，并去看专门帮我处理脚趾的人，不仅我看脚趾和X光片的人会知道，我的初级保健医生也会知道，这样他也可以查看我的情况，或者如果需要的话她也可以查看我的情况。第四个组件是可及性，即你实际上可以预约的概念。预约是可用的。此外，在PCMH中，除了预约之外，还使用了其他方法，例如电话辅导或电话外展，以帮助患者获得所需的护理。
And the fifth and a very important component is that care be safe and of high quality. That's really critical because as we've learned, one of the most important things I think in important. improving care is to closely monitor patients and to see how they're doing so that if they're not doing well, you can adjust treatment and make sure that their needs are met. And if they're doing well, you can be really happy about it and help them to continue doing what's working. The other part of that is that healthcare organizations are encouraged to really engage in quality improvement projects. Well, great. Well, thank you, Dr. Osarno for speaking with us today. My pleasure. For more information and to see Dr. Rosarno's work, please go to our website, speakingofpsychology.org.
第五个也是非常重要的组成部分是护理安全且高质量。这真的至关重要，因为正如我们所了解的，我认为改善护理最重要的事情之一是密切监测患者并观察他们的康复情况，这样如果他们情况不佳，你可以调整治疗以确保他们的需求得到满足。如果他们情况很好，你会为之高兴并帮助他们继续做有效的事情。另一部分是鼓励医疗保健组织真正参与质量改进项目。太棒了。非常感谢阿萨诺博士今天与我们交谈。不客气。有关更多信息并查看阿萨诺博士的工作，请访问我们的网站speakingofpsychology.org。
With the American Psychological Association's Speaking of Psychology, I'm Audrey Hamilton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我是奥黛丽·汉密尔顿，来自美国心理学会的《心理学访谈》。本期节目暂无评论。点击转录中的任意句子即可发表评论。